and I paid 7:50 a.m. I
didn't have too much when the gentleman
was talking earlier I didn't find out
earlier what I'm doing
I'm at 5 6
so from this second summit
we're going  many colleagues sometimes in
doubt who are now for
aincuses
not not
present who represents this
political Europe it is like a key and above all
the treatment of organizing this
second in Moldova to do it and at the
outposts of our Europe as
close as possible  precisely
for
Ukrainian
and
witness of determination to all and
the commitment also of Moldova on
its European path it is a
very strong symbol in itself which shows
no member of the European family
so this summit we have made it possible
to reaffirm our support  to Ukraine,
which suffered from a year and Russian aggression
and then an interview on the jungle with the
president of the skis we have together
a joint declaration,
in particular the support obviously in
terms of armament preparing the
counter-offensive we reiterated
our agreement  and more on May 14, 2023
let's also say there to the elements of
protection in the face of the Russian contract with
air defense equipment here
we have confirmed that we are
also listening to put in place the
necessary framework to start the training
of fighter pilots the Ukrainian according to
the needs of the air force students
as you know
the video
considering also
parallel consultation with the united states
volunteers we have instructed
ministers
with the formal framework is the
mechanics training mechanism this will be done
on the  in the face of the needs expressed by the
party,
we also have to be if you
really want to seriously discuss
our before we finish
strong coordination against Europe to prepare in
particular the Venus summit
of the summit bears witness to this, but all
the countries which have been able to come back here
j  I learned that part on the
logistical aspects not retentuelles on the
communication and the security of this
summit of the food which are
obviously given but you wish to be
realized this week in a way
benefit of the world population in
addition to all that we have
done with  the European Union in
recent months as the deployment of the
mission vs civilian deaths to fight
against the
managers we have a European censorship regime
produced stabilize Moldova or even
the association mechanism
Catholicism in Europe I regret
that precisely the
preparatory work  of this second summit of
the CPE and allowed
yesterday with the previous one but Sando to
react to the fresh desires between
the European Union and the moldine a
very agreement it allows to expand the remix
that we have Europeans to a
fashionable urban drop therefore  it is a
very clear initiative on the side made thanks to
the commitment of the European Commission
and also to the commitment of our
operators therefore orange as head of
kitchen
of migration and energy which were
discussed
there are some concrete initiatives
facing  to the cyber attacks to which
several States are subjected we have
decided to extend the cyber reserve to
all the countries which wish it
within the European political community
this cyber reserve that we
have launched within the
European Union is  the ability to
develop common centers
of expertise to protect us against
cyberattacks we have recognized the extent
of this by developing
centers of excellence in several countries
which are volunteered at the CPE level
is the same thing that we
decided for the protection of
critical infrastructures subject that
had already come out of Prague we have in
fact a methodology of the
protection systems that we have put in place
within the European Union we have
recorded their extension to  all the
member countries of the European political community
that he wanted and third
thing we defined the need to
better protect our public opinions
against the manipulation of information
and precisely the intrusions and
the use of social networks part
of propaganda  and on this
point coordination work has been
launched to be able to have
concrete decisions and also mechanisms for
discussions with the platforms in
the coming months
this meeting has also enabled this
summit has also enabled
coordination in different formats
I  We will come back to this if you wish in
the context of questions, but we have been
able to do so with Chancellor Schols to
follow up on the work that we launched
the last time and following the events
that have happened in northern Kosovo in
recent days we have seen  on the one hand
president haussmannie then
president vuchich and we have just
had a meeting at 4 for a moment by
bringing the two presidents around
the table and precisely asking
for clear decisions for
next week I will come back to this if you
wish in the  framework of the questions and
with President Michel the Chancellor
Scholtz we also brought together the
Pashinian Prime Minister and
President Alif to continue the
process precisely between these two countries
and to allow there also a pacification
between Armenia and Azerbaijan but
which is respectful  the sovereignty
of each person and the security of
people, as well as respect for minorities,
subjects which are very dear to us,
these two subjects illustrate that our
Europe, in order to continue to move forward precisely in the
context of this war in
Ukraine, needs to settle the conflicts
which remain and the situations of
destabilization which remain it is our
duty and it is a necessity for our
collective security we have done it
with the respect that each one owes to
all of its members but with a
real commitment in particular
Franco  - German very strong on this agenda
a last word finally to reiterate with
force how much this format this
community that we have been building together
for a few months is essential at a
time when our continent is facing
very great challenges and this community
on its feet  of equality because we
are 47 alike allows us to
meet the challenges together and not
simply with a center that looks at
the periphery if I may say so
because that's how we look at
things when we see them from
Brussels sometimes  when we discuss
things from the perspective of accession,
we are in tragedy and it is a
truly
intergovernmental approach, full and complete
it is I believe a very political Europe
which can thus meet its challenges we
will continue with the same spirit of
solidarity of respect and units in
grenades in October since this the
Spanish presidency of the
European Union which will organize the third
summit of the CPE then
next spring in the United Kingdom since it is in the
United Kingdom which will organize the fourth
session  I will now answer
any questions you wish to ask
good evening Mr. President
Valérie Leroux from Agence France Presse
we are a few kilometers from
Ukraine we are also very close
to a Russian base in the heart of Moldova
what is the message  that you are sending this
evening to Vladimir Putin chancellor
scholls said for his part recently
that he was ready when the time comes to
resume contact with the
russian president when will that time come
when do you think you will be able to
resume contact  with him president
zilinski on his side asked
today that a very clear signal
could be sent to his country at the
NATO summit that he could
join the TEC alliance the war
would be over is that  that you think
that this clear signal he will be able to obtain it
in Vilnius and will France support
this request
thank you for your questions first of all
France has always been available to
speak with everyone
and you know this on several  times
since the beginning of the conflict I had
the opportunity to discuss with
President Putin
if the opportunity arises and depending
on the content I do not exclude myself
today
there is no matter to  a useful discussion
if the questions of civil nuclear
security on this aborigia require it or
if there are advances of the openings which
allow it it is justified I
will do it without any hesitation in the same
way we do not stop  discuss with
all the countries that can play a useful role, whether
or not they have been in support of
Ukraine from the start, in order precisely to
broaden our base of support and avoid
any partition of the world, the message
that we subsequently delivered to the
Russia and clear it is a message
of unity and
unanimous and clear support for Ukraine and the
Ukrainian people
to carry out its counter-offensive to
obtain guarantees of security and
basically to build a lasting peace,
that is to  say respectful of
international law and the conditions defined
by Ukraine
I believe that Vilnius must
send a very clear message of support
to Ukraine and to the Ukrainians
I said it yesterday I for my part am in
favor of  there are
stronger, tangible and very clear guarantees in
terms of security,
we will have to coordinate to
prepare for the Vilnius summit and we
will also have to give
Ukraine long-term prospects, that is
what is up to us to prepare,
but it is  it is imperative that the
Venus summit be able to give this strong guarantee
new credible guarantees a
clear perspective to Ukraine and here
too a clear message in the
current context to Russia
the president
s are going to declare that Moldova must
become a member of the  European Union in
2030 is it realistic in
your opinion will Moldova be ready
in this year to become a member of
the European Union thank you
first of all I want to tell you how
proud I am for my part  that under
French President of the European Union we
have taken this step forward to
recognize the candidate status of
candidate for membership of Moldova,
it is a very clear choice that has been
made when we were making this gesture
to  Ukraine, we could not leave
Moldova out of the
content of its geography, of the
geopolitical realities which are in your
territory and of the courage with which
you have also faced this conflict
from the start in terms of
destabilizations in terms of energy
and  humanitarian plan
then when I see the courage and the
clarity with which the president Maya
sandou carries out the reforms the fight against
corruption the improvement of the
economic framework the work for the media and
their independence the work for
justice etc etc I have a  great
confidence in the ability of your country
under its authority to move
very quickly on this path then I
said it yesterday in Bratislava I think
for my part that we Europeans must
take our responsibilities
and accelerate with clarity on
enlargement while changing  very
deeply the nature of our union
thus enlarged
hello Mr. President I am here I am
raising my hand
Agnès baume from Bloomberg news a
question on the conflict between Koso and
Serbia so if I understood correctly it
would be a  meeting
next week with Chancellor Scholtz and
the presidents president of Serbia of
Kosovo that you just mentioned on
the conflict itself how does
it impact
Serbia's European prospects and do
you  join the American call for
an immediate de-escalation and to
bounce back on the question of my concert
when the security guarantees given to
Ukraine what concretely
such a security guarantee could look like
on the Israeli model that you
mentioned yesterday in Bratislava is
today you mentioned a
consensus that is emerging
today and a consensus with
Germany at the level of the main
European partners,
first of all we are working on this subject
of security guarantees to Ukraine from
very closely with Chancellor
Scholl it is all of our
European partners I will have the opportunity
to go to Germany next Tuesday
for more in-
depth discussions with the Chancellor among
others on this subject
we have the  desire to build
clear and stronger guarantees
than what we are doing
today
and I was saying this yesterday, it is in a
space that is between the level of
guarantee that we have given ourselves to the
Israelis and
everything that goes with a plain accession
to NATO which is not immediately accessible
the questions of the prospects
that we will discuss but I think that it is
in this space there that we will have to
build precisely something
credible and strong, but we need a
very clear message of support and
immediate guarantees and we need
clear prospects we have
today with Chancellor Schulz
seen President Bucci then seen
President Haussmann and then today
we have brought together the President  you chic
and President Haussmann as you
know Germany and France
proposed a plan
which was accepted by both parties
several weeks ago under the
supervision and authority of the
European Union and High Representative Borel
this plan and I believe a real step forward it
must now be implemented
there was an orchosovo of the tensions that
arose
last week which were linked to
the regrettable organization of elections
while the guarantees of good
unfolding were not provided and
four seas who were elected with less
than 5% of the voters' votes which is
obviously not a condition of
legitimacy an escalation of forces and
that it was during an escalation of
violence etc and I  want to say here,
moreover,
our full support for those who
were injured during these events,
in particular the NATO soldiers
in this context,
what we have asked the two
parties and very simple
the organization as soon as possible
new elections in these four
municipalities on
the part of Kosovo's commitment
the participation in these elections in a
clear manner on the part of the
Serbian side and the priority and
immediate resolution of the question of
the Association of Serbian municipalities
of the  part of Kosovo
here in essence it is to
greatly simplify things the request that
we have made and therefore
each party will now consult
its own and come back
next week with clear answers at
the same time the High Representative Borel
will have  the opportunity to hold
a meeting with the ministers of the two parties
precisely on the issue of
the Association of Serbian Municipalities
good evening
[Music]
for the world the logical conclusion of
what you have just said about
the enlargement which must go on  as
soon as possible it would be for France to
hold the opening of negotiations
this year with Ukraine and Molavia
with Ukraine and Molavia on
accession to it of course is that
the case  thank you so as you
know first of all we are expecting in the autumn
the report which will be made by the
commission but I think that now
we are entering a very political phase
and I said it yesterday globe I think that
we need
to acknowledge the fact that our
European Union must today anchor the
Western Balkans, Moldova and
Ukraine in our geopolitical space
and to think of ourselves fully as a
democratic power
by doing this the imperative and to
reclarify the aims of our
European Union and  its mode of operation
we have already changed and the
first wave of enlargement finally the
last wave pardon for enlargement
but which was substantial has changed the
nature of our union
and therefore we must remove its ambiguities and
accept to have  a union which will be
enlarged which is geopolitical it is necessary to
reclarify it by simplifying both the
competences and the purposes and then
to record that some of its members
in a system which must be open
perhaps will decide to go further
we  a more community-based and
more integrated policy within it
you have to have a much
freer mind but it's time for
geopolitical ambition it's time to
reinvent our frameworks we are
already operating too slowly at 27
no one can say
credibly that at 8 more we are going to
function better that is not true and
therefore at the same time that we are going to
have to accelerate in the opening we are
going to have to accelerate in the ambition
of the reforms their simplification and the
clarification of our purposes  this is in
any case the agenda that I will pursue in
the coming months
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen and
congratulations again to Moldova
for the perfect